[Música]
analizamos todo lo que tiene que ver con
la guerra en Ucrania tras la elección
unilateral de Rusia de cuatro
territorios ucranianos y la caída este
fin de semana de la ciudad de limaman
saludamos entonces a Genaro beristain él
es el profesor de política Internacional
de la UNAM y el Tec de Monterrey Genaro
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana el lunes en directo América de
Francia 24 primero conversamos sobre las
implicaciones que tiene la anexión de
estas cuatro regiones ucranianas a la
federación rusa y que sigue no tipo en
lo que tiene que ver con la estrategia
de guerra de Vladimir Putin qué tal Muy
buenos días Muchas gracias por la
invitación pues es un paso más en la
estrategia que ya tenía predeterminado
Vladimir Putin y sus más altos allegados
en este sentido el cambio sustancial es
que ahora en el momento en que son
anexionadas a la federación rusa
no es una operación militar que trata de
defender a rusos en otro país sino que a
partir de este momento ya sería la
defensa del territorio nacional de Rusia
lo que le permitiría hablar y mimir
Putin tener mayores cartas políticas e
incluso tener más aceptación por parte
de la digamos la sección rígida ortodoxa
del del gobierno de Moscú no Entonces es
un cambio sustancial de hecho son dos
repúblicas más o bueno dos territorios
más de los que en algún momento se pensó
que podría anexionarse Rusia Entonces
estos territorios cortan de Tajo la
posibilidad de que Ucrania tenga una
salida al este al mar Negro y que pues
desde ahí pudiese crear una ofensiva
posterior para retomar crimea Entonces
ahí sí viene un cambio sustancial en
cuanto a lo que está viéndose en el
desarrollo del teatro de operaciones Qué
puede hacer la comunidad internacional
Genaro para tratar digamos de alguna
manera de proteger este territorio
ucraniano no Y hasta dónde estaría esa
línea Roja de no cruzar para no escalar
a esta guerra digamos
armamentísticamente hablando
Bueno es muy significativo si la
comunidad internacional no reconoce la
anexión Pues en Rusia va a tener todavía
una serie de problemas para poder
justificar ante la comunidad
internacional el hecho de que haya
tomado esas regiones y que pues bueno no
la comunidad internacional al rechazar
podrán seguir manteniendo una serie de
sanciones en contra de Rusia aquí lo que
deberíamos tomar en cuenta es si a lo
largo del conflicto que tal parece
todavía se va a alargar mucho más en
algún momento Ucrania acepta esta
digamos estas secesión lo cual Pues
bueno llevaría a otro tipo de
complicaciones pero hasta el momento
mientras el gobierno lo está encabezando
hasta que el selenski salga del gobierno
o pase algo pues Ucrania seguirá
manteniendo el reconocimiento de de
crimea y de estas Este regiones que de
manera unilateral en este momento se han
anexado Rusia también generar el
presidente ruso blademir Putin dijo que
Ucrania debería volver a la mesa de
diálogo precisamente cuando está
haciendo esta anexión de estos cuadros
territorios a la ucranianos a la
federación rusa habladas de una
posibilidad de A lo mejor de que el
presidente selenski pues reconociera
esto lo ve sobre la mesa tendría que
hacer esto celenski para volver a una
mesa de diálogo que por el momento se ve
muy lejos
está muy lejos la mesa de diálogo porque
las recientes victorias del ejército
ucraniano le dan esa perspectiva hacia
lensky de que puede expulsar de su
territorio a los rusos el problema está
en que se leenski necesita de la ayuda
internacional para más seguir
manteniendo el esfuerzo de guerra ahora
bien Todavía no entran en combate estos
300 300.000 reservistas que mandó Llamar
Rusia desde su población vimos en semana
recientes que varias personas intentaban
salir de Rusia para no prestar servicio
militar Pero por supuesto había otras
personas que con mucha
fanatismo quizá podamos decir esa
utilizar esa palabra por supuesto
corrieron a las oficinas de
reclutamiento para ingresar y participar
de este esfuerzo bélico en contra de
Ucrania entonces mientras
Ucrania tenga victorias en el campo del
teatro de operaciones no se va a sentar
a negociar por otro lado mientras Rusia
esté retrocediendo Pues eso no le da
digamos una posición de fuerza para
poder negociar muy bien en la mesa
entonces tendrá que cambiar el teatro de
operaciones digamos que tendría que
venir una nueva ofensiva rusa para que
se obliga a selensky a sentarse en la
mesa de negociaciones si a esto le
sumamos que pueda haber algún tipo de
cambio en el apoyo internacional porque
el apoyo internacional no va a ser
infinito en algún momento se tendrá que
acabar ese apoyo tanto amar
armamentístico como político
no sé qué tanto puede impactar El
Triunfo de la ultraderecha en Italia y
que empiece a marcarse algunas grietas
en la comunidad europea para seguir
manteniendo las sanciones en contra de
Rusia ya que se acerca el invierno
entonces
tendría que estar atentos hasta ese
momento Claro en el terreno nuclear
vemos que últimamente Rusia y por
supuesto también el presidente vea mir
putina ha hablado de las armas nucleares
Incluso el portador del kremlin
dimitriscov dijo que se podrían usar
armas nucleares cuando se ve amenazada
la integridad del Estado ruso aquí
obviamente entramos en esta anexión de
estos cuatro territorios Herson lugares
Perdón henson saporiya Daniel no
Entonces cuando digamos Ucrania puede
luchar contra los rusos en este
territorio el que lemín puede verse o
puede decir bueno ustedes ya me están
atacando se ve amenazada pues la
integridad de mi estado y ahí pudiera
entrar entonces las armas nucleares en
funcionamiento o no es tan fácil tampoco
no yo creo que no es tan fácil el
escalar un conflicto a la capacidad
nuclear nos llevaría a otro escenario un
escenario que no creo que ningún
político esté dispuesto a pagar el costo
o sea por supuesto Vladimir Putin en
ningún momento Quiere pasar a la
historia como el presidente que destruyó
el mundo no o el presidente que generó
una guerra con capacidades nucleares no
yo creo que es parte de de La retórica
del discurso político pero yo siento que
Ucrania Perdón que Rusia tendría otro
tipo de elementos este para poder vencer
en el teatro de operaciones antes de
utilizar armas nucleares podría aceptar
la ayuda que le ha brindado Corea del
Norte o Corea del Norte le proporciona
hasta este momento le ha ofrecido cien
mil efectivos militares altamente
entrenados y capacitados Irán
ofrecido drones para continuar con su
esfuerzo bélico y la República popular
china pues ha estado comprando el gas
Ruso y ha estado prestando dinero
también la India ha sido un factor
fundamental entonces antes de escalar a
un conflicto nuclear creo que Rusia
tiene muchas más opciones Esperemos que
así sea y también genarontes de
despedirlo quisiera hablar de la ciudad
del imán que cayó a manos rusas este fin
de semana o gran parte digamos de la
ciudad la importancia de esta urbe y en
el terreno que sigue que se quisieran o
que les conviene tomarse a los rusos en
territorio ucraniano
bueno Yo supongo que obviamente estamos
aquí en el escenario de la suposiciones
Y yo supondría que Rusia se está
retirando para no desgastar sus
efectivos Y hacer que se estire lo más
posible la ofensiva ucraniana para en el
momento en que tenga tropas frescas
pueda entrar con más fuerza en el teatro
de operaciones la caída de la ciudad de
este centro ferroviario muy importante
para el abastecimiento de tropas rusas
hacia una nueva ofensiva pues marca un
debilitamiento de la ofensiva de que el
kremlin ha tratado de desplegar pero
aquí yo quisiera aclararle al público
que pues en la guerra como diría Claude
bitch no no hay el resultado no es
absoluto no O sea en cualquier momento
puede cambiar el teatro de operaciones y
sobre todo pues en este momento
podríamos hablar de una victoria sino
que hay distintos grados de derrota